this battle scene in spider-man far from
home wouldn't have been possible without
Harry Potter the matrix or even James
Bond the midway fight sequence called
the illusion battle was partly inspired
by these movies although the movies
visual effects were completed by a
combination of companies Framestore was
responsible for this thrilling section
visual effects supervisor Alexis
washboards who previously worked on Thor
Ragnarok and Doctor Strange explains to
us how it was done and spoiler alert
we're going to be revealing details
about the film in this sequence
spider-man visits what he believes to be
the Berlin office of Europol but instead
is a trap set by Mysterio the villain
uses holographic techniques and
projected rings to create a sequence of
horrifying illusions usually the process
is there is a script and then there is a
production period where they shoot what
the script is and then we are doing
visual effects on top in first position
along the case of this one the sequence
was not locked at script stage we were
concepting at the same time as we were
animating shots to make a sequence like
this the shots must go through different
stages with 120 employees all working in
unison modeling texturing shading
rigging animating rendering and lighting
the shot the movie star Tom Holland has
his movements recorded in a motion
capture suit which is then passed to the
animators to begin the frame store art
department worked on creative references
with director John watts and VFX
supervisor Janek sirs
visual references included the comic
books as well as surrealist paintings
references on YouTube of cool videos
that we find with there were one where a
drone was emitting lights and watch that
the matrix for having a lot of agents
missed was our sequence where there is a
lot of spider-man jumping onto the main
Spidey
of course we looked at the James Bond
title seconds for Spectre we used that
reference for sequence in the graveyard
with zombie Iron Man with Marvel we are
doing a lot more in CG a lot more
completely computer-generated whereas in
James Bond's they shot a lot more
element and it's more 2d the team also
used the scene from Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix as a reference when
all's fall on the gang we wanted the
gloves to be actually Mysterio Club mr.
helmet to fall which didn't end up in
the movie will even look at Indiana
Jones having a giant glob of mr. Edie
chasing spider-man Evil Dead for the
mere seconds once the references were
locked the team moved a storyboard then
concept art in total 150 pieces of
concept art were produced these were
turned into animations the transitions
from one scene to another were
particularly difficult they used an FX
driven transition dubbed the buff effect
or by narrowly augmented retro framing
which is based on the transition used by
Iron Man in a scene from Captain
America's Civil War what we call a terms
of a blue twinkly effect which is lots
of blue pixels what is it that we can
make it better so we transform this 2d
pixel into 3d voxels and and make the
effect a bit more 3d when you transition
from one environment to the other you
need the true environment to have some
similarities so for example at the
beginning we are transitioning from
Europol to actually a construction site
that's why we completely transform the
construction site in full CG we
completely rebuild it to make sense of
the geography so there is always a link
when you are somewhere in Europe or you
are somewhere in the construction site
the transitions were also inspired by
The Truman Show mainly the idea of
walking into a landscape but turns out
to be a different texture such as a wall
or a floor FX such as Mysterio's blast
or the smoke inside his helmet were
created by other vendors such as
scanline Framestore created the FX of
green smoke and applied it to different
environments the texture of the smoke
can be dry ice wispy or thick like a
floor
weather systems were a difficult effect
to achieve but this the team had to work
on the texture of different effects so
one that is actually more complex either
there's no interaction on spider-man and
the building piercings true it's really
tricky to have realistic snow he always
looks a bit like jelly or or - powdery
the sequence involved three main
spider-man suits the homemade suit as
seen in spider-man homecoming the
stealth suit and the homecoming suit
the scene is lit with strong directional
light which was a challenge for the
texture too thin and the soup starts to
show too much muscle definition too
baggy and the suit looks ill-fitting and
wrinkly
at one stage we see Spidey in a short
room where he looks at multiple versions
of himself all moving independently for
this the team had to create 20
individual animated spiderman suits they
also had to design the character suit
for zombie Ironman
we had some very very gory version where
we still see some bits of skin and
muscle and flesh which was a bit too too
far from marvel
we went full skeleton and well that was
nothing at cause it's a big challenge to
model all of these broken pieces of
metal as well as a scale and and and
then making sure that we shade them
correctly we also use the Avengers age
of Ultron as a reference because there
is lots of broken robots with the
hanging cables and hanging pieces at the
beginning of the sequence we use that as
well as a reference to see how we can
make a zombie Iron Man with all this
hanging a piece of metals the team had
worked on similarly tricky sequences in
Doctor Strange and Avengers and game the
previous Marvel movies actually what we
cannot do so we looked at Doctor Strange
okay we cannot do all of that
spider-man have got sliced into lots of
different species in space but because
they've done that in endgame already we
couldn't do that the sequence took nine
months to make from first reference to
finish product which was no mean feat
given its scale and complexity
[Music]
you